[Music]
I've been paying for a while now I feel
like the chessboard has just been thrown
up we've got fertile ground now we don't
know what's going to grow of it I think
there's you know the traditional labels
of left right are becoming meaningless
what really is a Republican in the age
of Trump which is sort of a different
thing than conservatives of all that do
you think that the next wave of politics
is really going to be about the
realignment I hope so I hope so I do I
know I know you've been talking about
this a lot on your show you know this
this split between authoritarianism and
whatever you want to call it
libertarianism small-l broadly conceived
right right that's what I hope do we
need a better word for that because I
think because I do believe that's what
it is that it's authoritarianism versus
libertarianism but I think when you say
libertarianism people think of it as
some sort of option strange political
parties there is there a better phrase
then yeah I mean so for instance I have
many differences with libertarians so
people often lump me in with them and
but ask a libertarian I mean asked like
a hardcore libertarian about Thaddeus
Russell that's like oh he's not a
libertarian I have many differences with
them although in some things I very much
agree but they're they their hostility
to or opposition to the state and state
power I'm completely with them on that
I think markets are very responsive to
consumers needs and I think they advance
humanity in many many ways I don't think
they're perfect I think capitalism is
perfect and that's one of their problems
but anyway I do think that general idea
that basic idea that we should be free
from control by others those in
authority in particular those with state
power which is the monopoly on violence
right is a good thing so I love that
about them and I love that about this
sort of new formation I see happening
and you're a part of that and some of
your guests are part of that versus
Democrats and Republicans who do want to
control us right liberals and
conservatives who do want to control us
in various ways I would like to see a
new realignment around that I would like
to see us talk about politics in those
terms because the right and left and
think you're right no longer mix make
much sense unless you're very specific
about what you mean by them right so
we've talked a little bit more about the
so far and you know my feeling I'm
trying as a liberal I'm trying to clean
up what the left is and at this point I
don't think that being a liberal and
being on the left or even compatible
unfortunately but let's talk about the
right a little bit right what is right
authoritarian ISM right now right-wing
authoritarianism is sort of what we know
I mean it's using the state to control
people's personal lives so you know it's
they don't want women to choose to be
able to achieve abortions they don't
want us to actually they're very
concerned about popular culture so they
want to control what we watch and listen
to you know they don't like a lot of
Hollywood they don't like a lot of what
happens in the music industry they've
held marches and protests and called for
laws to censor those things and they
also want to control what happens in the
rest of the world in various ways they
want to send out the United States Army
to control how people think and behave
now the thing is that lately and I think
again this is where you've been going a
lot with your show is that there's been
a convergence between the Conservatives
the Republicans and the Liberals the
Democrats on many of these questions so
for instance hip-hop here we go
popular culture if you look at the
reaction to hip-hop over the last 20
years the negative reactions but calls
to censor it it was tipper gore it was a
lot of feminists and it was Christian
conservatives joining together al
Sharpton was another one who held
marches against hip-hop you know calling
for music companies to shut down these
these artists and censor the lyrics so
there's a lot of convergence around this
authoritarianism yeah so where does
Trump fit into that yeah because he
doesn't care about video game violence
or words that are in rap songs or even
abortion I don't think he particularly
cares about certainly not about gay
marriage so those things that are
thought of as right authoritarianism all
these people that are marching with
hashtag resist are they sort of missing
the boat on who they should be attacking
on it would have been a great thing if
he had had more than two or three people
in the world who agreed with him
we're in Washington DC yeah things right
so unfortunately he brought just a tiny
little crew to Washington and had to
fill all these posts you know all these
jobs and the only people available
unfortunately were Christian
conservatives and generals right and so
what
we have it in Mike Pence and Mike Pence
comes from the Christian conservative
right conservative wing and they've got
their you know their hold on him
sessions I think is another one right
the who actually thinks that marijuana
is dangerous to people I mean it's
phenomenal the guy as an absolute
neanderthal on this stuff I do think
that he's not going to be successful
because I think that that war has been
won by us you know but but it's it's
it's unfortunate that Trump I think he
feels beholden to them he can't hold any
power without the Christian conservative
base and so he's not being really
forceful in his championing of popular
culture which he comes right out of
right now I mean look at who he is he's
the Venus of yeah his wife is a model
and you know all the rest of it I mean
that's so yeah so Trump and that's one
of the reasons I think that he makes
people crazy in fact I actually think
that's the main reason he makes both
sides liberals and conservatives
absolutely lose their stuff which is
that he is that he breaks those rules
cultural rules so if you look at if you
look at Puritanism right what I was
talking about the work ethic what does
Donald Trump do mm-hmm
he got a bunch of money from his dad and
he kind of lives large on his private
jet everything is in you know everything
is covered in gold and what who does
that other than Donald Trump rappers
yeah we think about this right he does a
lot of the stuff that you know the bad
black people have done they celebrate
their bodies and they don't care about
you know conventional rules and norms
and Buchwald morality and all that stuff
and you know he's he's not shy about
talking about sex that's also something
you can't do as an absolute taboo he
breaks all those cultural rules I
actually think that's why they go crazy
about Donald Trump in a bad way because
basically they don't know how to fight
it because they are constrained by sort
of other rules right it's it's so
fundamental to who they are and their
what their world is when we walk around
in America generally speaking we don't
talk about sex we just don't it's the
silence that we impose on ourselves we
all are proud of when we work hard even
if we don't make a nickel for it right
it is so central to who we are we've
internalized it it's not like people
walk around saying oh I'm a Puritan and
here's the pleasure
it's just it's completely deeply
embedded inside of us
since the Puritans got here and that's
what Trump just seems to not seems to be
oblivious to sort of the depth
fundamental American culture and I would
say it's really a middle class culture
so working-class people of all colors
have generally speaking and immigrants
to have kind of avoided that stuff they
haven't internalized it of course
because they're sort of outside of the
the realm of power and they're outside
of citizenship right and so for whatever
reason I don't know why Trump is much
more like them even though he's always
been a rich kid he sort of adopted that
kind of working-class indifference to
bushwa morality and it people can't
stand that what does that tell you about
politics sort of between the ideas and
just the cult of personality yeah you
know as someone that you obviously care
about ideas you have a command yeah
because you were born out of certain
ideas that you later challenged and it's
sort of incorporated into what you do
now but basically everything you said is
just this is just cult of personality of
what he's doing there's a fundamental
very depressing problem that I'm sort of
just coming to grips with or coming to
terms with now in my own life which is
that and I sort of known this all along
but it's really hitting me hard is that
even with the internet even though I
think people are better informed now
than ever before because of that the
vast vast vast majority of Americans
don't know anything about politics so
the obvious reason spending time on
Twitter this is a problem no matter what
your politics are as a public political
person or a public intellectual you know
people don't even like that word and and
it's all it means is you're a lover of
ideas that you're curious about big idea
is and you talk about ideas that's it
you know people don't even like it when
you use that yeah it's mug kind of I
know eyed smug is the word of them
called recently more than once it's a
it's a problem I mean for what we do
right it's you know we so that's why we
those of us in this little world talk to
each other most of the time yeah right
because most Americans have never heard
of Syria much less know anything about
it you know most Americans I mean look
at the polls it's just most Americans I
think don't know who the vice president
is it's something like that I mean they
could they can't identify Washington
DC on a map you know huge portions of
the American public don't know anything
is that just a function of our success
that we are perhaps the most successful
nation in the history of the world we
have done tremendous amounts of good
we've done plenty of bad at the same
time we brought in more people from
every walk of life all of these things
we've created the system that basically
still is pretty great and what you get
out of that after the sausage is you get
sort of a dumbed down thing because
people have video games and have leisure
and sports and all those things yeah so
I think those are good things that I
think yeah well I I think yeah it's
pretty great that doesn't mean there
aren't problems and I wish more people
cared about ideas and all that but that
it's just the function of success is
yeah some of this yeah you don't need to
care about stuff you don't need to think
you don't need to read Foucault and you
can spot all you want about what he
thinks but you don't need to read them
right because no one does so there's no
one's ever checks you on it right but
that's right um so yeah I mean it's like
I often say to people like you and me
it's like are we sure we want to be
doing this when we have a better time in
a better life if we were just following
sports instead in a sport I got funny I
had Jason Whitlock from Fox News went on
a couple weeks ago
and he was so you know clearly
passionate noses thoughts and all that
stuff about politics in the wider world
and then when he left I was like man
that guy gets to talk about sports I was
like that would be pretty great if I was
an NBA analyst no I know but we do love
this that's that's I don't know I mean
aren't we control economy for my look I
love it well you do but you're also got
Richard by it
yeah it's exhausting when when when the
articles and publications call me all
right extremists yeah you know and then
I have to go well now do I want to spend
my day fighting this or just letting it
be or but it all it's fighting that's
what it is right and so half the time I
love the fight and half the time I hate
it I don't know what else to say I mean
I don't know what else I could do I mean
I would love her to be like a boxing
coach instead I don't think I can and
I'd like to be in the NBA right probably
not deep so you know you know Jews used
to dominate basketball I know in this
country oh you know that I know I know
whether there were a lot of Jews in the
early days of the NBA now
dominated to a predominated 40 with the
bad so you could bring that back you
know now that I think there are no Jews
man yes you could be the first and I
wanted you that's pretty sad I've heard
that Jordan Farmar is half Jewish guys
until illegal that's about it he man
they got him out they found out about
his house yeah I think they actually
sent it to Israel but alright so it
would totally cyber boy I want a book is
a little more on that on that right
authority I everything because it isn't
the part of the authoritarian stuff that
I focus on a lot so I do want to spend a
little more time to okay part of it
doesn't make sense to me like it seems
to me that on something like gay
marriage if the right that supposedly
believes in states rights and in the
individual and in local limited
government all those things they had
such an easy opportunity to do the right
thing with gay marriage now of course it
got screwed up because of the Christian
conservatives but even right now with
marijuana as you're talking about with
Jeff Sessions it's like you guys are the
ones that are supposed to care about
limited government and not having the
government tell people what they can do
in their own home why are they unable to
take a principled position here it well
I don't know about being okay well I
think for me that did I lead too much a
no no no I think that conservative or
republican authoritarianism is different
in a very important way and it's the
reason that I like you focus much more
on left authoritarianism which is that
they are dumber no really they are less
effective at getting authoritarian
politics out there and distributed and
and bought into the sessions this is
what I was talking about sessions right
good luck buddy like convincing America
to roll back legalization of pot it
ain't going to happen right you're
certainly not going to convince anyone
of this stuff I mean no one no one
believes other than Jeff Sessions really
the pot is harmful to you in the ways
he's talking about but they what does
that say that that even President Obama
yeah was still having the feds shut down
their local things like here in
California is my point that is exactly
what I'm saying here so that sessions
won't be able to do it Obama could
because everybody loved Obama because
Obama played by all the rules because he
was the perfect American man and he was
black and so he he kind of
star are bad history for us too he made
us feel better he was our salvation he
was he was perfect he was almost a Jesus
figure and that's real and I mean that
people really did treat him that way and
I don't think that's an exaggeration if
you look at it right and so he could
send in the feds to shut down marijuana
dispensaries and no one batted an eye
yeah certainly on the left but why did
he why did yeah I see what you're saying
on the what he can get away with it but
why do you think he did is most likely
he doesn't really care about marijuana
laws do you I don't know I would say
that he like like people in the
progressive left and I include liberals
in this are interested primarily in
social control so they need and that's
not it's not saying that they're evil
that's just who they are they like a
well-ordered society so I don't know but
I would suspect and look at Obama he's
like the paragon of discipline right he
is actually the perfect Puritan at least
as far as we know right I would say
that's part of it that he didn't like
the fact that people were violating
federal law and I think getting high I
think he now sees as disruptive right
it's not a good thing
so look at his sermons here you go
sermons or lectures or speeches whatever
you want to call them an interesting
choice against black culture which
people sort of don't pay attention to
but he gave many every time the guy got
in front of a black audience he would
start lecturing them about watching too
much ESPN and about how they needed to
pull up their pants and how much how
they needed to work harder and raise
their children right and stop eating
Popeyes Chicken
google it I mean he went and Michelle
did the same thing this really Stern
admonitions of black culture so I think
that's all of the piece I think it
probably plays into why he did go after
the dispensaries yeah doctor there's a
lot there so we're where we started
before we went on this 20 minute
roundabout was I was mentioning the the
you know the outcast sort of the the the
drunks and all those people and then I
said I was sort of like some of the
people that were in your house growing
up and you were making instinctive those
are not the same thing so let's think
you go back to that house good I had it
there
we were going to get that was very good
yeah
so the the Communists in my house
growing up were puritanical because as I
said earlier you know communists and
socialists have always been puritanical
again this is lots of literature has
been written on this this is not just me
talking Lenin and Marx were opposed
sorry Lenin and Trotsky were opposed to
homosexuality not because some of
sexuality was sort of bad in itself but
because it was decadent so decadence was
the problem for communists throughout
the twentieth century they thought like
Adorno did later that it was this thing
that was leading the working class the
decadence popular culture consumerism
was leading the working class astray
what the working class should be doing
instead was organizing themselves for
revolution now here's what they
understood this is why it's all logical
they understood that when you control or
manage a whole society which is what
they wanted everyone to do that requires
tremendous discipline you can't be going
to the movies if you're going to be
managing the economy right and so that's
what they said I mean this was this was
their argument we need to instill this
perfect proletarian discipline was the
phrase in the Soviet Union and elsewhere
and so my parents comrades came out of
that tradition they were Trotskyists you
know they came out of that and they
understood that so they may have watched
some television but they didn't they
thought at best it was just an escape
right and what we really need to be
doing is studying GDP figures right and
so so that we can manage the economy
everyone should be doing that everyone
should be an engineer and everyone
should be ready to have meetings all day
long and all night long to organize our
society so it's so interesting because I
don't as you're saying that I was
thinking that recently I've been saying
this thing about how comedy I think is
dying right now to that there are n
comics willing to cross line we've got
Bill Maher apologizing for a word even
though no one in their right mind thinks
these races we've seen so many leftist
progressive comedians just making the
same Trump jokes over again and not
really pushing the limits of what comedy
is but with what you're saying it really
does make sense why they almost can't be
funny
this is what I've been saying that these
progressives who are shutting down pop
culture in these ways are true to their
heritage this is what progressives I
mean the progressives the original ones
of the early twentieth century did they
shut down the Nickelodeon's they did
they in every city in the country
progressives launched these camp when
these days can you tell people what
Nickelodeon's are no sorry there's a lot
of people my younger audience is going
to think you mean with the green goo
sorry that's not what you mean yeah the
the Nickelodeon Network is named after
the cinemas in which started in the
Lower East Side of New York grew and
spread all over the country which were 5
cent cinemas you could go and put a
nickel in and you could watch a movie
yeah although I'm sure they probably
wouldn't go after the green goo at some
point too because there's got to be some
racial connotation to that yeah so the
progressives in all the big cities shut
down those Nickelodeon's because the
working-class was watching burlesque you
know or you know just or things that
weren't about work and you know
discipline and war and so yeah it's it
there being true to the heritage yeah we
should have culture that is completely
austere right and and not fun or funny
in those ways that's why the left is so
unfunny right think about it I mean it's
so earnest they're so earnest that they
can't make a joke
well that's the thing they've been burnt
Pepe and tank
yeah and kekaa Stan and all that they
birthed it because it's these people
online that have just had it with the
political pregnant so now they're
sending out frogs with swastikas just to
get a reaction out of you
yeah and people that think it's hate
speech I had worse is there I had Gavin
McInnes on my show and you know it
became very clear to me about five
minutes in this is what's happening he's
hilarious much of what he says is either
racist or pretty damn close and the
content of what he's saying I have a lot
of trouble with I don't know how serious
he is about it but it's it's clearly
right-wing in in pretty bad ways
according to my politics but he's really
really funny he has the freedom to do
that comedy requires freedom Jim goad is
another one you know he he just
approached me he wants to be on my
podcast and he but he and I started
looking at his writing much of what he
says is
probably racist probably sexist probably
homophobic but he's hilarious he's very
very funny so what do you do yeah what
in other word what I want to ask you
that what do you do with that you
personally what do you do with that when
you're sitting across from something
like that right I don't know I laughs
yeah and I'm troubled and I feel like if
they are not however I feel like it's a
day like with Gavin McInnes he has no
real power right I mean no one's going
to listen to him and write some policy
based on this you know you could say he
contributes to the Trump phenomenon but
what's the Trump phenomenon I mean there
is no Trump phenomenon anymore the
generals have taken over basically you
know yeah once they attach themselves to
any movement that might cease state
power
oh then give me an ak-47 right but these
guys are so marginalized people talk
about being marginalized the
marginalized are those guys and what
they represent it's so interesting you
say that because that's the other reason
that I focus on the left is not just
because I come from it but also because
I see that's where all the power is
seated the conversation seated there
Hollywood is see they're all buzzing so
when they get you know the three white
supremacists to show up at a meeting
somewhere and then of course the media
blows it out of proportion as if there's
Nazis rent you know rampaging through
the street it's like you're you just
need that need that belief do you think
that's a fair oh absolutely
oh yeah noted yeah I mean so they
control most of the media it's just true
okay liberals liberals mostly not really
socialists but liberals control the
media for the most part other than Fox
News and Fox that's eight well by the
way if you've ever been in the Fox News
greenroom you'll know that there's a lot
of liberals who even work there right
hope the people behind the scenes they
stood I knew gay people that work there
and all sorts of York City Upper West
Side oh yeah exactly and they control
academia and they control what's now
being called the deep state whatever you
know if that's yeah they're all others
or whatever but you know in terms of the
civil servants right to work in
Washington DC and work in all the state
capitals it's over we know this is
overwhelmingly liberal so yeah this is
why I get upset because they control the
world that I operate in they determine
my fate in many ways
[Music]
you